hi I'm Malika dot and i'm the president
and founder of breakthrough a global
human rights organization i'm really
pleased to be at the World Economic
Forum on India where I had the privilege
of participating in this really really
interesting conversation India Indian to
Indian looking at solutions for India's
future and I actually loved the format I
really like the fishbowl format because
i feel like it creates a dialogue where
we interact and get much deeper into the
issues that we're looking at in terms of
growth inclusion equality certainly
women's rights i'm thrilled that the
forum is highlighting the issue of women
this year because i think that for India
to really grow to be to its maximum
potential we really have to pay
attention to the status of women and
women's rights in this country I've been
a part of two world economic advisory
councils i was on the India Council and
I was on the Human Rights Council and
I'm always so pleased to meet the
amazing diversity and talent that gets
represented in these faces